on sait que l'industrie du taxi à
montréal veut se moderniser pour mieux
concurrencer le service
hubert jean-sébastien cloutier le chemin
est encore long parce que le nombre de
plaintes
encore cette année en 2015 est énorme ça
pourrait même est une année record
peut-être oui selon des documents qu'ont
obtenus grâce à la loi d'accès à
l'information le bureau du taxi de
montréal a reçu entre le 1er janvier
2015 et le 11 septembre dernier 4 185
plaintes et si la tendance se maintient
on pourrait friser sinon battre
effectivement le record qui était de
l'année dernière imaginé avec 727
plainte et on va préparer un petit
tableau
en 2015 les problèmes les plus souvent
rencontrées par exemple manque de
courtoisie des chauffeurs revient 80
fois le non respect du code de la
sécurité routière 37 plaintes le refus
d'effectuer une course 30 de la course
qui est non sécuritaire jugé non
sécuritaires 31
l'itinéraire plus long que nécessaire 30
alors on aurait pu vous en lire
longtemps des plaintes mais on en a
retenu 1 écoutez bien ça patrice ça fait
réfléchir
résumé par le bureau du taxi monsieur
est employé à l'hôtel ritz-carlton comme
chasseur dans ses tâches il fait souvent
appel à des taxis pour la clientèle de
l'hôtel
il est très déçu du service offert par
les compagnies et les chauffeurs en
général les voitures sont mal propre le
personnel mal éduqués mal engueulé la
perception des touristes est très
diminué le personnel de l'hôtel fait
appel plus souvent au service de hubert
et hubert ex imaginez alors le bureau du
taxi est conscient qu'il ya un problème
qui a du pain sur la planche fait
beaucoup d'inspection travaille à un
nouveau plan d'action mais tient quand
même relativiser en rappelant que chaque
année à 18 millions de course de taxi
sur les de mourir je laisse écouter la
toute nouvelle directrice générale du
bureau du taxi linda marchand
on est convaincu que la majorité des
chauffeurs travail avec
professionnalisme mais il ya toujours un
pourcentage qui nuisent à l'image de
l'industrie et notre objectif s'est
redressé la barre
on travaille aussi présentement
diagnostic de la formation continue pour
voir si la formation qu'on donne
présentement chauffards et qu'on
n'oblige les chauffards suit est ce que
ça répond à la demande maintenant de
2015 et on va tout arranger ça pour
réviser sa
alors faut dire quand même que
l'industrie peu à peu se modernise des
compagnies de taxi maintenant offrent
leurs propres applications mobiles et
depuis le 15 octobre
tous les chauffeurs de taxis sur l'île
de montréal doivent obligatoirement
offrir le service de paiement par carte
de crédit et par carte de débit
le bureau du taxi fait les inspections
et promet de serrer la vis si ce n'est
pas respectée et pour vous dire j'ai eu
une expérience personnelle ya quelques
jours ce n'est pas encore respectée par
tout le monde
voilà merci enfin c'est au revoir